we are here with a very special guest
today a fellow sweaty a man in so many
comic properties I am proud to welcome
David s mulch in hello how you doing man
I'm awesome how are you guys thanks for
having me on today very excited very
excited you also represent like one of
us on the inside and that makes us very
happy thank you thank you this is a this
is like the the friendly confines of
home being around a bunch of people we
were just before the camera even started
rolling I feel like talking about long
boxes of comic books so there you go but
it's awesome to be here thanks for
having me guys but you're also here
because you are many multi-talented and
you've just written or have written a
movie that is now coming out everywhere
yes very soon very soon is here below we
have May 17th yeah all creatures yeah
thank you very much it's really exciting
you know we made the film I wrote it in
14 and then we shot it in 16 and now
it's 19 so the journey is long in a road
yeah and and it feels it's it's
nerve-racking this is that time in the
process that is it's very exciting and
you you know you're you know audiences
are gonna finally gonna get a chance to
see this this story that you've told but
it also is it's it's horrifying because
it's like your baby lack of a better
term put out into the world and and it's
a difficult film it's a tricky film it's
a film that has lots of layers to it
it's really complicated and it's um it's
a film that I think it really challenges
audiences and it's for shocking and so
there's a lot of stuff that you go you
just have to trust you know and I'm so
proud of the people that came together
to make it so I'm excited to share it
with the world and we've gotten you know
distribution from one of my favorite
film companies the Sam Goldwyn company
that is putting this movie out into the
world so that it's just the miracles
that have happened in getting this film
to a release are beyond
I can't count anymore you know and Sam
Goldwyn seeing that logo when the movie
queued up there's such a warm positive
like there's so much of our childhood in
that in that world and that iconic logo
as it swoops in when you were building
this movie how did you see it landing
like did you imagine this bit of a
release like where did you see don't
even I didn't know I just I I thought
that you know it's it's I knew as we
were filming I was like well this is
definitely because the nature of the
story and the way that things unfold in
it it's not what you traditionally call
a commercial film does have a commercial
plot so I was optimistic and hopeful
that people would get to see it probably
at film festivals and then you you know
you hope that that after it's a Film
Festival run which is generally where an
arthouse film like this gets a lot of
its audience and then word-of-mouth
would grow and build and um and so that
kind of is what happened you know we got
to premiere it downtown Los Angeles last
fall and then we've got to play Glasgow
and in Kansas City in some really
wonderful places but a player like Sam
Goldwyn you know coming along having a
company of that nature see our film and
say we believe in this movie and we want
to help you share it with the world that
I didn't see coming and it really really
blew me away in a beautiful way and I'm
just I'm so thrilled and honored and I
can't wait for you know this is such a
interesting time in the career
trajectory of the triple-threat that is
karen gillan because she's an actor as
we all know her scope she's like she's
like a Daniel day-lewis
I believe she's transformative in that
way that she embodies characters that
you don't recognize from film to film so
if you look at oculus or you look at
Doctor Who or selfie and then you watch
what she does is nebula or in Jumanji
then you look at her own film which she
wrote and directed and starred any party
just beginning that's a person that
we've never seen her you know even
there's no hint of any of her other
characters in that and then which she
did for all creatures here below is yet
another fully realized embodiment of
somebody that she's never she's never in
come close to inhabiting I mean she
brings this thing this character this
story to life in a way that um it's very
humbling for me is the guy who wrote it
and who acts alongside her in it and
it's I'm excited for for people who are
familiar with her work to get yet
another level of the depth of talent
that this woman brings to cinema it's
really amazing so you have some pretty
great leads for your movie there's some
good the baby is amazing baby steals the
show the baby was actually played by
twins
yep they Reagan and Maddie they were so
awesome and the only problem with our
poor babies was that they didn't cry as
much as we needed them to a lot of sound
design because they were just a sweet
happy easy babies
and this is my second collaboration with
Colin Shipley who directed the film and
he's super talented and such a wonderful
friend and so many awesome talents came
to play david koechner and jen morrison
and the incredible John Doe who plays my
uncle in the film and oh god that guy's
so good so yeah I loved seeing Dave
Koechner plays such an earnest
performance that wasn't like he's always
that guy and it was great to see not
playing against type of playing a
different type everyone in this role
they got to play roles that were so
juicy and powerful and heartfelt and I
like that when this movie came out the
buzz around it was an indie opportunity
for these Marvel actors to play in a
different wheelhouse yeah and when I was
watching it I was thinking I loved
blockbusters but man I miss movies like
this and I really appreciated the fact
that I forgot the late 80s Early 90s
sensibilities of movies just being this
low to mid-range budget and having all
the heart you need to keep you going and
this movie never sacrificed heart for
story and it was a hard story to tell
when you were writing it was a hard sell
to get anyone behind it to get actors
like it's very hard very hard in the
beginning I so I had been living with
this story for a very long time I'd say
decades I just been creating this
narrative that I thought was really
interesting and interesting narratives
are a very important part of filmmaking
but they're not everything so the plot
and these characters the idea behind it
very Steinbeck I mean he is one of the
hugest inspirations for me artistically
you know John Steinbeck Tennessee
Williams Sam Shepard Carson McCullers
all you know theater and lit American
writers that had a huge impact on me and
that spoke voice that their voices
reflected a truth from the place where
I'm from which is the Midwest of America
as well and I feel like Steinbeck in
particular is always shown as a light to
me and what I hope to achieve as a
storyteller so this movie is a love
letter in one sense from my my love of
of John Steinbeck's
you know story and craft and then films
like Badlands which is legendary classic
and inspired me a lot and I've
at numerous times in my in my life films
like raising Arizona which I've always
felt like granted that's I straight up
wacky comedy but it's also got so much
heart and the moments that it catches
you are you know can be all the feelings
so so I so I've been living with that
plot living with that plot let me this
idea thinking about this idea this I
really knew I saw the plot in my mind
but what was missing from it was the why
like I didn't have the question I always
have to have a question when I'm trying
to write a story and I something like
basically within my my family my
immediate family about six years ago
seven years ago there was kind of a
bombshell revelation of sorts about one
of the really important members of the
Family Circle and child abuse that had
taken place and and and it was something
that once it was verbalized I was like
oh oh my god yes like we all knew we're
aware of or in proxy - and yet something
that had gone for decades
just being buried in the family cellar
if you will of crap that we all do
collectively as families we you know
sometimes just push things down and
sometimes they're left and you hope that
they never resurrect and sometimes when
they resurrect you realize that we never
killed that zombie it's more powerful
than ever and so then this the the the
things started really clicking for me
and think about Ruby and Jensen yes
they've they've taken these things that
they feel have been denied them just
like so many people in our culture have
been denied so much for reasons that are
both we can call fair unfair whatever
that's not for me to decide but she Ruby
wants a baby she wants a family so bad
and for reasons we don't know yet she
can't have her and then she starts a
family Jensen wants some financial
security for once he wants to feel like
he can support her take something that's
not theirs they have to go on the run
they have to go back to where they're
from and now they're hiding and yet
having to confront the thing that
they've been hiding from their whole
life so that's what started me typing I
finished the script Colin my director
was on one side he was on the other when
I started typing literally we were on a
plane flying to go talk about our movie
animals and they both read it cuz they
read everything as soon as I finish
there my first line of defense and they
both said like this is the best
than you've written let's go get it made
so then this the process started and
luckily I work in other films as an
actor so I'm able to interact with
people and I was working on a wonderful
film called chronic and the producers on
that read the script loved it helped
introduce it to another producer who
started helping putting financee
together that producer really they all
kind of wanted a chance to ask if any
more and maybe named actors would be
interested in playing the role of of
Ruby and I said you can go ahead and
send they think they're gonna send it
like three different people and I was
like no one's gonna no one's gonna say
yes that's fine and Karen Gillan's agent
gave her the script and she read it and
she came right over and met with us and
said I really loved this film and I
would love to be a part of it crazy that
I personally as I mean this is clutter
heroes so I have a strong love of that
world but I personally love that actors
that are in these tent poles get to do
the smaller films in between they get to
invest their time and these other things
and then people might find them because
of their love of nebula like someone
might find a film they might not
otherwise see and that's an amazing
thing about cinema is the highs and lows
of budgets doesn't mean the highs and
lows of quality because they're both
such strong films that couldn't be more
different and they might find the same
audience and that's amazing I'm so
grateful that I get to be apart for so
many reasons obviously the the
nine-year-old first holding and Avengers
kid in me that is that has been obsessed
with comic books in this culture but
that's that's my that that I get to do
that and then make small films and they
feed one another they really do I
learned so much on the big sets I
interact with the best artists and then
they help me give advice on my little
films it's a great urban flow if you
will but yes I mean you know Kansas City
let's go back to the 80s all the sudden
and I am you know walking into that
7-eleven on one-hundred and third and
Mastan and I think it was actually
called a minute stop at that time it's
now a 7-eleven I believe but I it is
spinning rack and there was an Avengers
number 249 and it had a door but a bunch
of the Avengers were lined up and and
and they're facing they're facing us as
if it's a camera shot ready to fight and
I just I was obsessed and I
took it home and I traced and drew on it
I still have it in fact when I met Stan
for the first time Stanley I brought
that with me to show him that I've kept
every comic since the first one I bought
and he took it without even asking but
I'm glad he did and he had a sharp and
he said and and I'll tell you the
beginning part of the story first but he
said what's your name what's your son's
name again I said Oh Arlo and he wrote
to my good friend our Oh Stanley and he
signed it to my son I have it framed
above my desk but right before that I
had said you know I've kept every comic
that I've ever bought and I started with
a Marvel comic and and I've keeping him
so someday I'm so excited to give him to
my kids but I'm also afraid I'm going to
show them my comics one day and then
they're gonna be like me how do I throw
a curveball or something I don't know
that I could tell you like when X Factor
was formed in oh you don't want to hear
that but whatever yeah I have to from
the beginning of your comic career is a
movie that's hugely important to me I'm
a giant dark knight fan I think that the
dark knight is is I just at the bar
because that's not a fair statement but
man it is when people really try to take
them seriously and you got to be part of
that and that was that was a very
beginning of your career how was it to
be on that scale of movie from the
beginning and and I got to hear about
Heath Ledger because I mean Heath
Ledger's is everything I mean it was it
was it was everything that you could
possibly probably imagine being somebody
from our background and someone who was
so obsessed with and and so so yeah the
Marvel superheroes were always my
favorite and the DC villains were always
my favorite and the Joker of course is
one of my favorite characters in modern
literature and I think in the modern
mythology and the mythos what he
represents and what scares us so much
about him and yet why we still want to
keep watching the car crash is the
brilliance of that character so I knew
that he was going to be a part of the
second film cuz I love begins I knew
that they were filming in Chicago and
here I was an actor struggling to start
making a living I was doing some
commercials but mostly theater doing
plays in the city and they yeah they
held it auditions for the bank heist
clowns and I got to go in for that and
from that audition the casting director
god bless him brought me in the next day
to read for for mr. Nolan and
they decided that I would be right for
this other role so fast for they didn't
all happen quickly you know I I
auditioned and then I didn't hear
anything and I knew that they shot the
bank heist sequence so I was devastated
but the the fan that I am I was doing
Othello I think six days a week two
shows on the weekends and we're off on
Mondays but they were filming The Dark
Knight on Mondays and Monday nights and
I would look online find out where they
were filming and I'd go with my little I
still had I didn't have a cell phone
camera that I liked yet I was using a
click and disposable and I would go to
sets and stand behind the barricade and
just watch hoping I'd catch a glimpse of
any of the process for months later is
when they offered me the role of the
thug without telling me any details
about the character and I showed up to
work my first day of work having been
fitted into this cop uniform and I asked
why am I trust that the policeman I was
told I was one of the Joker's henchmen
and they said oh they're very secretive
you'll you'll find out when you're meant
to and I walked into the hair and makeup
trailer which is always a magical
placement I love going like in when you
start your day as an accurate you get to
set you know you go to your trailer or
whatever sometimes you get in your
wardrobe and sometimes you don't to
start the day but you will always go and
go to hair and makeup and and the first
people that you interact with is that
team of artists that team of artists was
a very special group of people on that
film and it was a day that we were
shooting one of the big parade the
funeral parade sequences and so everyone
was in the trailer and I mean everyone
it was Gary Oldman and Christian Bale
and Maggie Gyllenhaal and Aaron Eckhart
and Nestor Carbonell and all these
actors who I loved so much and then at
the end was Heath Ledger and he had his
music on and he was getting the Joker
makeup applied and I just and I was
afraid to talk to him because I know I'm
playing a small role and I don't want to
be annoying and I also want to respect
people's boundaries he came up to me and
welcomed me that day we talked all the
time he was super cool super
down-to-earth he was I was just I was my
I was close I was I was like this I was
that close like trying to peek at the
makeup and being blown away that I was
standing next to the Joker and the
interaction we had which is really funny
I'm sure I've told the story before but
I said I I see he said how's it going I
said this is crazy this is insane I
can't believe this he says yeah I can't
believe it either and I said you know
when I first heard that you were gonna
play the Joker I thought that was a
terrible idea
just funny I didn't think I mean I was
joking but I I mean I remember when I
heard he was cast as the Joker I was
like really Oh what really the I mean I
think he's a good actor but the Joker
and he go he this is so perfect he was
like yeah he's like so did I and we hit
it off from that point for it he was
always so sweet to me
and so cool and so kind and he liked
Karen Gillan like all of my favorite
actors i I've ever been able to you know
be in the share space with or perform
around watching him fascinated me
because he was such a warm humble
soft-spoken gentleman talking maybe
about you know the Chicago or music or
something and then he need to go shoot
and he he just his mastery of his craft
and his talent and his ability to become
a character that was unrecognizable it's
that's magic to me I mean it's craft its
skill it's talent it's a lot of things
it's discipline but there is a magical
quality when somebody is this guy
talking to you about something and then
you know excuse I'm sorry I'll be right
back
and then they're just like something
else yeah
that's insane and you've been able to
transition into both sides of this comic
lore starting with that and like you
know ant-man the hair is as important as
anything else like you talk about the
hair being an important part of the
process like let's say who see this
movie and then go back and catch up on a
men are gonna get something quite you've
done how do you land a name the comedy
side of things I was very lucky because
a comedy is not a skillset for me at all
and I it scares the poop out of me and I
and I went to so I auditioned the
godbless Seraphin she brought me into it
she knows what a comic book nerd I am
she brought me in to audition for
Kirt in the original incarnation of
ant-man which at that point was being
directed by Edgar Wright and she I came
in full character very different looking
character than who we now see in in the
ant-man movies I had shaggy ER hair and
a gold chain and stuff but he was in
that ball park so I did my audition then
she brought me back to read for Edgar
and I read with Edgar and then I got to
do a test which is where they bring you
to Disney and they have a set kind of
basic set set up with cameras and they
have the actors that are up for the
roles and at that point the gang the The
Wombats if you will was there was more
than three of us in that script at that
time I want to say there was maybe six
guys in the game there were this late
crew this high screw there's a lot of
guys there who were testing for these
roles and what they do is then they have
some scripted scenes but Paul's
obviously been cast at this point he's
there Michael Pena has been cast at this
point he's there and they want to see
how we interact with them and how we do
scenes so we're doing scenes and I'm
like I'm dead in the water you guys
because all these guys who were around
me were very funny and really good and I
could tell they were gonna like bring it
so my strategy was because I felt like
my character was very sardonic and like
could give could give a crap can I say
he's just going to sit back so I just
sit back like on couch with the pretend
coffee like watching them to see and
whenever I get line maybe I drop one
little bit because there was so much
amazing fireworks of comedy happening I
felt like I got really lucky that I made
that choice because it kind of stood out
in that crowd it was just like little
bit so so needless to say we then went
into like a green room in between and
Paul was really nice to me and he was
like that was it was really funny and
and and then and then the fast-forward
as we all know there ended up being a
creative difference between Marvel and
Edgar Edgar I ended up leaving the film
and I found out that you know oh my gosh
no I'm I had been cast at this point and
now Edgar's gone and the film's gonna
completely change I don't know what's
Cap'n and will I be a part of this I
didn't know find out maybe a month or
two later they found a new director
Peyton Reed I'm a huge fan of Peyton's I
never
met him before then I got a call from my
manager another month after that you're
going to go to Atlanta to do a test and
so I'm thinking okay I have to do
another audition another test so I fly
to Atlanta and I was sitting in a small
table and there was Evangeline Lilly and
Paul Rudd Michael Pena and Marvel
executives and they were showing us the
ant-man helmet and they were doing like
a demonstration of stuff and I'm still
just like this is cool of them if
they're if I have to go through this and
I don't get this role and then Peyton
comes over and he's like David I'd spin
so crazy sorry we haven't gotten to talk
but I'm so excited to have you here
and I was like hearing like what way
like I I thought we were doing I could
test he's like no we're doing we're
doing we're doing camera tests he's like
we're doing more tests like of your hair
and your costume you're in my movie yes
you reading anything good lately oh I
was just
I just finished monstrous on my land and
I felt like that's the level and layer
of storytelling that we should all be
like aspiring to with comics cuz man
it's dense it's almost Frank Herbert
dense you know it's like I love it
it's really great oh sure Lou right so
no takeda drawers she won the Iseman
last year y'all know if you're watching
Collider heroes an icepick gateway drug
for a comic fan if they haven't read any
comics haven't read anything yet if
they're just coming in blind I pick up a
Detective Comics I feel like that's such
a good way to get hooked into art and
story and plot and character and the
villains are always the best I mean I
love the caped crusader don't get me
wrong but it's just something about the
people that whip his ass make me to fill
me with joy and I have to bring this up
because the desk we're at one I'm
excited for June like you wouldn't
believe I'm so excited and Baba Yaga is
one my favorite lines in Marvel so
congratulations on that moment but
Peyton Reed giant MODOK fan
Jon Schnepp who began this world is the
biggest MODOK fan I know in the world I
finding out Peyton was a MODOK fan made
me very happy
you actually introduced me to a MODOK
item I didn't know existed there is an
ice cube maker you have that prints out
Lodox yeah as a final story how did you
find this beautiful thing so I got this
amazing package from loot crate I love
loot crate and I love getting like just
just bundles of nerd goodness okay but
there was one that was
it was it was it was coming around the
time of the first ant-man and so it had
a lot of ant-man centric stuff in it
which was so cool so I ended up getting
a bunch more because there was like a
measuring glass that had being
incremental sizes from Antep to Hank Pym
there was plates there was some really
neat stuff but the MODOK Ice Cube maker
it's a you know those fancy kind like
you'd have like a highball you put a big
Cuban but it's Mota and I so I sent I
got extras sent to pave them and Payton
freaked out man he loved it and here's
the funny thing I think that I am the
biggest nerd like I'll show up on set
and I think that I know everything about
about stuff and Payton is such a
passionate devoted to comic books and
his understanding and his you know how
he works in that world I think it
reflects and how good of a filmmaker he
is but it's really fun for me when we
get to geek out about some of them
because I'm an obscure guy you know I
mean my favorite characters are Morbius
and Moon Knight and I was the West Coast
Avengers collector I wasn't it I bought
a first comic was an Avengers but I
actually started in third third grade
going into fourth grade it was that
monthly arrival of my West Coast
Avengers are going to my comic shop
those Tygra Wonder Man those are
characters that I really get excited
about well as Suicide Squad develops
we'd love to have it back on so we can
talk just that for an hour but your
movie is incredible wanted to make sure
it got all the love congratulations on
that going forward after five years of
moving and grooving one Suicide Squad is
more talked about able would love to
dive into that as well I've not heard of
it thank you it means a lot I really
appreciate it and I'm really proud of
this so thank you for for letting me
come talk to you absolutely you
absolutely should be it's a magical film
Congrats on Sam golden Congrats on it
existing and congrats on a movie this
good and this type of film getting to be
made I check out the movie may 17th May
17th thank you guys so much thanks for
joining us thank you till next week say
sweaty guys and check out clatter heroes
every Tuesday see you guys every Tuesday